We met up with the Cheekyboyos
who make crazy challenges for over
10 million followers on TikTok.
They brought 11 different items
for us to play with.
And each time we win a point
our racket get more difficult!
Two beginners with real rackets
vs
two pros using random objects.
And we brought some good ones.
We brought some good ones.
So you better watch to the end!
0-0
I'm nervous I'm nervous
Oh. Got it.
Who are you cheering for?
CHEEKY!
YEAH!!
Who's for Pongfinity?
*awkward silence*
Do we get a chance to
try the surface?
No, no, no.
Yeah, you see it!
You see it!
You see it. You see it!
They don't.
They don't know what to do!
Oh o!
Spin move!
LET'S GOO!
Let's do it. Let's go!
OK!
Okay guys, what's next?
This
Yeah.
Nice!
That was brutal!
Keep watching!
Let's see
Move on
to the books.
I don't know how fast this is.
Oh, it's fast Otto!
Good thing is...
the more we lose,
the more we win.
OK,
next one!
Otto, you show!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Just keep it in play!
Nooo!
YES!!
Come on!!
I'm not going to lie,
This means everything!
Yes.
Got the serve in!
Yeah. It was nice.
It was good!
Thank you!
NO!
No problem.
Looking good!
Looking pretty good!
Yes!
I got greedy!
It's okay!
Guys, you're going to share an iron
Not the first time.
me and Otto are sharing something
Tell us more about that...
They're charging up!
Pretty intimidating!
No, it's really fast.
I forgot to tell you.
Yeah, you should have shouted:
"Miikka it's fast!"
The faster we go
the harder it is for them!
WOAH!
No way. No way.
NO WAY!
That was actually such a crazy one!
Come on!
That was incredible!
I can't believe he returned that
from you.
That was very impressive!
Very impressive.
If you ask me, guys are going to lose.
So badly.
We didn't ask you...
Sä pelaat Brianin kämmenelle ja mä pelaan
Now they're switching languages!
What you don't know is
we know Finnish, so.
We're about to Finnish You guys!
oh, it's over again.
You guys can iron my clothes for me.
You can move on to the next one.
Not going to take that!
no.
We have to be aggressive!
Six-all, six-all
tie game
This is only getting better for us
I think we got this!
What the?
Straight attack!
That could have taken a while
To be honest we weren't expecting that.
No, I wasn't.
Because if I was, I would have
hit it back!
Nice!
Emil was doubting us two points ago
He was. He was
How's it looking now?
I have to say it's looking better now!
Yeah.
Can we get some advice?
What do you think?
We need help...
I have never played with those paddles.
Maybe you have to hit harder.
Harder?
Do you think we have that in us?
You hear that?
We got to hit as hard as we can!
Just a little harder.
Thank you very much. Thank you.
Yeah.
Scared?
See that!
gave us a little bit of coaching,
and it's easy.
Go for it!
They're nervous now.
You can feel it
Look at their faces!
Come on!
That was actually a really good serve!
Oh, guys.
He's pulled out the number one serves!
See all we had to do is
go get a little bit of coaching.
Yeah,
There was something special about that.
coaching.
Me and Otto are gonna go
What can we do?
Just punch a hole in it
and make it flat
Then catch it
and then roll it.
Yeah!
That's cheating!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Match point!
Right?
By the way guys,
where did you get those balls?
What's going on?
This might actually go like,
terribly wrong or something.
No, no, our plan is...
What?
"That's cheating!"
Take that!
Sorry about the balls.
They we're our balls!
We brought these!
We weren't expecting that
That's pretty clever, though.
Coaches' advice again.
That was your suggestion!?
Unbelievable.
Guys, guys.
You know what!?
Do the same thing!
This is the best thing ever!
They didn't think of this
when they were choosing the items
I'm sorry guys...
NOO!
This is how we're going to play the game.
Where you gonna go?
Pongfinity is just cheating now,
I guess
Ten-ten
Get your spoons!
We may have cheated our way
into the final points,
Um, maybe...
I have a really bad feeling about the spoons.
Yeah, it's not going to work out.
Good luck!
I'm going to be, like,
down here somewhere.
Do they play with spoons in Finland?
That was better than the real racket!
Oh my gosh
Bring out the Lamborghini
*intense car noises*
Most expensive paddle in the world.
The front mirror came off.
You broke our car?
Yeah.
Wouldn't be the first thing they broke of ours.
OK. Match point!
OK. OK.
It's their serve now!
The switching technique.
They don't know what to do.
no!
Hit it deep!
Yes! Come on!
There's nothing we could do.
One more. One more.
I'm not even mad, we got like
five shots on with a mini car.
Eleven-twelve
Match point!
One more
It's a win in itself.
If we get the serve on the table
Very good match!
Well done. Well done.
Congratulations!
To the winners.
You get to keep the Pongfinity rackets
Thank you so much.
And to go with those,
you get,
A net
Whaaat!
So you just hook it up to any table?
any table.
Oh that's sick!
We're using that!
Are you seeing this?
huge thanks to the cheekyboyos
who joined us.
Remember to go and
Check out their TikTok account.
They do hilarious stuff.
Subscribe to them, though, for real.
They got to win something!
Thank you for the audience.
Thank you so much. Thanks so much, guys.